حسنًا ، أولاً كما قال الرئيس المنتخب بايدن
بعد وقت قصير
من مقتل قاسم سليماني ، لن يبكي أي
أمريكي
على رحيله بكل دماء
الجنود الأمريكيين التي كانت على
يديه ،
لكن السؤال الأساسي الذي أحرقه القانون
والذي كنت أطرحه في تلك القطعة
كان  هذا الإجراء يجعل أمريكا أكثر أمانًا ،
هل تحمي مصالحنا الوطنية ،
وسأقدم لك بعد عام واحد
إجابة على هذا السؤال هو أنه لا توجد
إيران أقرب إلى سلاح نووي اليوم
مما كانت عليه قبل عام واحد ،
وقد شجعت إيران على مواصلة هجماتها
على  الشحن والبنية التحتية للنفط
في الخليج ،
رأينا وكلاء إيران يهاجمون
المصالح الأمريكية في العراق على
مدار العام الماضي
ولا يزال هذا مصدر قلق مستمر ،
لذا فإن كل الوعود التي حصلنا عليها من
هذه الإدارة حول كيف
كانت سياستهم تسير نحو  حصولنا على صفقة أفضل على
الجبهة النووية كان سيوقف
السلوك الخبيث لإيران في جميع أنحاء المنطقة ، تلك
الوعود التي لم تثبت في الواقع
إيران تواصل  التصرف بطرق
تتعارض مع مصالح
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
ولا شيء عن الإجراء الذي تم
اتخاذه قبل عام واحد
اليوم أدى إلى تراجع في الواقع في بعض
النواحي في الحالة التي احترق فيها مشروع القانون وقمت بذلك
في حالة  سوف تستمر في صنعها
اليوم
هي أن الاستراتيجية التي تركز على
جانب واحد من جوانب القوة الأمريكية
وتنحي الدبلوماسية جانبًا تمامًا
ليست استراتيجية
ستحقق في النهاية
الأهداف الاستراتيجية التي
تريد الولايات المتحدة تحقيقها